- It's like drinking lemon juice.
(sighs) Okay.
Hi, I'm Hannah, your friendly
neighborhood Wine Mom,
and I'm drinking some
really, really sour sauv blanc tonight.
It's just like the fridge
leftovers, you know,
when you have the wine that's
been in your fridge for awhile
that someone brought to
your house and you're like,
"Oh, I don't really like this kind."
But, like, I'm not gonna waste.
My phone is shattered to oblivion
and every time that I text somebody,
I get shards of glass
in my fingers right now.
So tonight we're gonna talk about
the worst things about texting.
So first, when I text someone,
and I see the little
bubble appear in the text,
and then it disappears.
It's like emotional torture,
'cause I'm sitting here like (gasps)
(sighs)
(gasps)
Why would you do that to me?
'Cause it's always in response to a text
that's either emotional or time-sensitive.
I've tried to comprehend what
kind of situation could occur
where you start typing a
text and then you stop.
And the only explanation I could think of
is you were standing atop a volcano
and you're trying to take
a really great picture
of the center of the volcano
and then you drop your phone.
Whenever I text my husband
something very, very important,
like, "Do you want pizza
for dinner tonight?"
And he types something
and then I never get it.
Oh, you didn't text me back?
Guess what?
We're having tuna noodle
casserole for dinner tonight.
I suck at making tuna noodle casserole.
You could've been having
delicious cheesy grease bread with me,
but you couldn't text me back.
Next, the entire etiquette
of dating and texting.
Now, I haven't dated in a very long time,
but when I did date,
there was this weird time period
that you're supposed to wait
before you text somebody back.
It's like two hours is acceptable,
because you seem busy and unavailable.
I don't want someone
who's too busy for me.
I want someone who's interested in me.
So if I'm free, I will text you back.
If I'm interested in you,
I will text you back.
If I'm busy, I will text
you back when I'm free.
And it's not this, "Oh,
I better seem busy,
"because then he'll like me more."
When I'd be dating a guy and
text him and he wouldn't answer
for a couple hours, I'd be like,
"I know that you're sitting on your bed
"with no pants, eating a cheeseburger."
You are not too busy to text me back.
This too busy to text
persona is not attractive.
And that's why I married
a phone call kinda guy.
My husband likes to call people.
And that's why I love him.
So cheers.
Next, when someone sends me a text
and then immediately calls me
to ask if I got their text.
First, you didn't even give
me a chance to open your text.
Second, if what you had to say
was all wrapped up in a text,
why are you calling me to
tell me the same exact thing?
And my mom is one of the
worst offenders of this,
because she will send me a text,
it's like a picture of
a dress, being like,
"Do you like this dress?"
And then she'll call me
literally two seconds later,
being like, "Did you get my text?"
And sometimes the text
has not even gone through!
So then I have to be on the phone like,
"Okay, let me put you on
speaker, let me check my texts.
"No, it still hasn't, okay
now it's gone through,
"Now I'll look at the picture,
yeah I like the dress."
Next, when I get a text that
says, "Can we talk later?"
And it makes me so nervous!
'Cause I'm like, what is it,
do you not wanna be my friend?
Did I do something wrong?
What did I do?
I retraced my steps for
the last four months.
What did I do in the last four months?
Could I have pissed you off somehow?
What is happening?
So you're basically
sending me a text saying,
"Hey, I want you to worry
until the time that we can
"actually talk."
If you send something back saying, "What?"
They're like, "Oh, no,
we'll talk about it later."
In the time between when
you send me that text
and we actually talk,
I've formulated 80,000
different things that lead to
the world ending.
And then when it gets to the
time that we actually talk,
it's always something like,
"Hey, do you like my new haircut?"
Next, when I get a text and I read it
and I'm in the middle of something else,
and then I forget to answer
it for like two weeks.
This happens to me all
the time when I'm at work,
I'll be in the middle of a shoot
or I'll be in the middle
of a conference call
and someone'll text me saying,
"Hey, do you think I should
wear this shirt or this shirt
"to my date tonight?"
And I read it and I'm like,
"Oh yeah, I like that shirt,"
and set it down.
And I forget for like two weeks.
I'm a mother of two, I have
a husband who's very needy.
I work full-time.
I have a million responsibilities,
and it's really hard for me to remember
to reply to a text when
I've read it and already
like, closed it out and put my phone down.
Then it's kind of just, like,
out of sight, out of mind.
So then I'm the jerk who
two weeks later is like,
"I like the red top!"
I will take full responsibility,
I am so sorry!
I am a contributor to one of
the worst things about texting.
And last, group texts.
I have gotten group texts to me
and 10 other people at a
time, and it'll be like,
"Hey, just want you to know
"that my birthday party's this Saturday,"
something you could easily
text all 10 of us individually,
but no, you had to do it as a group text.
So then all 10 of those
people have to be like,
"Oh my gosh, how's your boyfriend?
"How's your life?
"How's your job?
"What's going on?"
All these individual conversations
appear within the group text.
And so I go to my phone and
I have like 87 notifications
of text messages, none
of which are for me.
'Cause when I delete the
message conversation,
I still get notified the next
time someone sends a message.
It doesn't take me out
of the conversation.
And it's so frustrating.
So the only way to get out of it
is to be that jerk who's like,
"Hey guys, can you take this to your own
"private text conversations?
"Because this has nothing to do with me."
That's all I had to say.
So that's all I've got for today.
I'm Hannah, your friendly
neighborhood Wine Mom,
and if you have any problems with texting
that you wanna talk about,
or a topic you want me to talk
about in a future episode,
leave it in the comments,
or text me!
And this is a real phone number,
and if you're very lucky,
I might text you back!
'Till next time!
Oh my god, get me off this group text!
(groans)
I don't care.